Miracle flights the sponsors of the
segment are lighting up downtown
Summerlin for some very special children
and their families here's why
we are celebrating the second year of
Miracle flights here in downtown
Summerlin spreading Joy with Linda and
Maddie now explain what Miracle flights
is for those people who don't know
that's right so Miracle flights has been
around since 1985. we provide free
commercial flights to those people
seeking life-changing Medical Care and
you can help provide those Miracles too
with a joyful visit to downtown
Summerlin we have lit up Joy we have six
gigantic illuminated words Joy love
Miracle soar all of those words really
embody the spirit of Miracle flights and
the spirit of the holiday season so when
you're at downtown Summerlin take a
photo take a selfie and you can donate
to Miracle flights one way our community
can help bring more Medical Care to
families just like Maddie's is to click
on this QR code takes us to our website
and you can donate as little as ten
dollars and while you give the gift of
joy you can meet a star so we're
featuring a different child at every
poster at every word just like Maddie
here here so when you're at downtown
Summerlin come by check it out make a
donation simple as that now Maddie and
her family have taken 16 Miracle flights
to Aurora Colorado so far keeping her
health and her spirits flying high so
what does joy mean to you Joy means
happiness I'm very joyful all the time
you are so beautiful thank you and so
stylish right look at that outfit you
know I had to ask Maddie what's on her
Christmas list and at the top is makeup
clothes and Miracle fights I need it
because it helps me with my disability
and the spine spinal muscular atrophy
that I have
and they helped me get the medical
treatment I need
well when you take these flights and you
work with the doctors you know how do
they make you feel
they make me feel very welcome and
comfortable because they're so good
there from dawn to dusk through January
1st you're invited to catch the lights
for flights powered by solub six words
for Endless Miracles can you name all of
the different words that people can find
I'm testing you right now Maddie
Joy a miracle
um
hope hope love
did we miss one did we miss one four I
cannot wait to watch you soar Maddie
thank you
I think we forgot peace we forgot peace
in there but yes thank you Miracle
flights for sponsoring that segment I
love Maddie and her family find their
lights for flights throughout Downtown
Summerlin for more just call
800-359-1711 or call or head to
miracleflights.org I'm going to ask